une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités
cette semaine Coeur de Pirate Béatrice
Martin en personne c'est vraiment un
honneur de la recevoir c'est une figure
emblématique le quand même au Québec
dans la musique ça fait quelqu’un c'est
quelqu'un qui se fait à peu près qui a
une quinzaine d'années son premier album
a complètement explosé je pense juste 18
ans d'en faire de fou moi je me souviens
du phénomène que c'était en 2008 c'était
big le tout le monde savait cette équipe
de pirates tout le monde avait l’album
de cœur de pirate
public
c'est pas content d'avoir pu avoir la
chance d'être entretenir avec elle de
parler de son parcours de parler de
comment qu'elle vit ça aussi de
l'intérieur les différentes périodes de
sa carrière qu'est-ce qui s'en vient
pour elle
qu'est-ce qu'on l'a quisition de
maison de disque bravo
très artistique c'est quoi sa vision de
tout ça c'est comment que
je suis vraiment content d'avoir eu la
chance de parler c'est toujours vraiment
cool de rencontrer des gens tu sais
qu'on
peut
idolâtrer parce que c'est pas l'idole
mais des gens qu'on estime beaucoup de
qui on consomme la musique des
personnalités publiques quand on
rencontre qu'on se rencontre au final
c'est juste quelqu'un avec qui on peut
chier et puis j'ai jaser
vraiment un plaisir on ne vous rend
beaucoup rire on a un peu niaisé c'était
comme une clé avec
ça bonne chance
de pirate
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
cyberGhost VPN
c'est un VPN ce que c'est en fait c'est
une application qui permet de plusieurs
choses de 1 garder l'anonymat sur
Internet on le sait internet on met nos
données partout on aura nos informations
les grosses corporations savent tout sur
nous ça va ce qu'on est savent qu'est-ce
qu'on aime il nous cite des pubs il nous
sur internet il faut être vigilant il
faut faire attention un VPN ça protège
ça on reste vraiment incognito juste
mettre le mode incognito sur c'est pas
sûr sur Google Chrome is naraf je vais
vous donner ça quand même VPN ça va être
pour ça c'est aussi d'autres choses
ouais ça vous permet aussi d'avoir accès
à des sites qui ont qui sont Go
localisés en fait c'est à dire que je
vous donne un exemple quand j'étais au
Colorado je voulais écouter des offices
sur Netflix mais Netflix
USA il y a pas de office fait ce que
j'ai fait c'est que j'ai utilisé un VPN
pour changer de location et d'avoir
accès au Netflix Canada pour pouvoir
écouter de Office et finalement être
capable de m'endormir parce que sans
dire je suis pas capable de dormir
[Musique]
ça donne aussi accès au catalogue
international de plus de 35 services de
streaming puis on a une offre pour vous
pour cyberGhost VPN qui est certain
durée légendaires écoutez ça cliquez sur
le lien en fait dans la description du
podcast pour avoir accès à 83 pour cent
de réduction c'est assez précis mais
c'est quand même massif 83% de réduction
et 4 mois gratuits offert par VPN et si
vous avez pas ça mais vous pouvez
conserver
sur le site le lien dans la description
du podcast et protéger votre identité
dès maintenant et profiter un maximum de
tout ce que Internet dans offrir merci
cyberGhost VPN cyberGhost
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
mandycape menscape
des frissons à chaque fois juste nommer
le nom
c'est comme un
d'un coup
mais on adore tes produits qu'on utilise
les utiliser ce petit bijou ici qui est
le billet de header pas plus tard que ce
matin juste en mode un peu laissé la
barbe aller au gris de sa volonté mais
j'avais juste un moustache un peu trop
long c'est juste un peu trop longue
qu'elle trempe d'embauche un matin
clic-clac juste tailler ça à la
perfection c'est un outil qui qu'on peut
avoir la longueur désirée on peut aussi
juste enlever le bout de plastique ici
vraiment trimer à avec une précision
incroyable
puis j'ai terminé ça avec la petite rue
là-bas la brosse toutes les kit ici pour
avoir une barbe incroyable mais Skype
c'est des produits c'est ils ont tout en
fait pour justement moi vous le savez le
ben j'ai pas donné déjà parlé peut-être
que si c'est la première fois que vous
entendez de m'inscrire vous dites c'est
que là c'est des malades mentaux là mais
j'utilise le body wash et le 2 en 1 pour
shampoing revitalisant honnêtement à
toutes mes douches puis c'est mes
produits préférés j'en ai testé beaucoup
parce que moi je suis souvent un Cloud
parce que je fais de la natation puis le
l'odeur de chlore ça reste longtemps si
tu as pas les bons produits le body wash
the man's Skype il sent bon il élimine
toutes les odeurs de chlore sur ma peau
puis il y a aussi le petit spray
hydratant leurs produits sont débiles
mental si vous allez voir le je vous
conseille grandement en fait déjà aller
voir sur le site et de vous procurer ça
à vous ou à un être cher utiliser code
promo sans filtre pour 20% de rabais et
la livraison gratuite c'est un sacré bon
deal et en plus ça leurs indique que
vous écoutez le podcast vous voulez
supporter le podcast fait que allez-y
courez sauter là-dessus merci man's
skate
oyé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la technique en fait en erothérapie ce
qui m'a expliqué cette semaine dans des
situations de désensibilisation donc tu
te mets dans des situations que tu
pourrais juger dangereuse mais c'est pas
toutes là
il y avait beaucoup de monde pour
justement me dire ok c'est correct si je
suis correct je suis en sécurité avec
une certaine distance quand même montant
faisait pas des parties non plus le
métier genre
c'était quelque chose qui m'angoissait
beaucoup mais je le faisais je me
forçais à le faire
c'est que j'ai attrapé la covidence
parce que je suis allée whitechanen au
final c'était seul
tu avais genre tu étais comme en mode
c'était vraiment juste parce que je
pense que quand tu es enceinte ton
cerveau s'il fonctionne d'une autre
façon puis je devrais vraiment super
super stressé mais c'est pas c'était pas
très bon pour le bébé tu sais mais
finalement cette chanson on s'en est
bien sorti là il est tout à fait normal
aujourd'hui il va bien maintenant on le
salue d'ailleurs c'était pas
retenu c'est toi qui a tout évacué tu
l'as tellement surexposé de peur de
mourir pendant que tu es enceinte que
lui
c'est comme il y a pas de fears de bébé
d'anxiété complètement
mais la théorie de l'exposition mon
neveu il faisait des crises d'épilepsie
la première qui a fait ma sœur a comme
tu as paniqué ton enfant est en train de
faire une crise à temps mais après ça la
deuxième fois qu'elle le fait ou la
troisième fois je sais pas le filmer
pour ensuite parce que ça fait de dire
que faut qu'à leur garde puis que ça
efface plus rien pour qu'elle puisse
réagir correctement quand la grille se
passe et comme des sensibiliser à voir
ton enfant c'est ton enfant
mais bon tout ça pour dire que mais tu
dis qu'il y a plusieurs types d'aucides
finalement mais moi je savais pas qu'il
y a plusieurs types de ça moi c'est
juste j'ai des réflexes comme ça
soit comme mes souliers soient comme
bien bien placés
installé très très très loin parce que
je pense que c'est comme comme je disais
quand tu es enceinte la façon de
réfléchir et pas nécessairement
rationnel puis j'avais déjà un petit peu
de ça à cause de la tournée parce que
quand tu fais de la tournée tu peux pas
tomber malade genre jamais fait que j'ai
l'impression quand même absolument parce
que tu es comme le seul
maillon solide mais ton site web tu peux
pas faire le concert mais que personne
qui travaille avec cette pression là est
énorme
donc en gros quand j'étais enceinte
j'avais déjà des réflexes de personnes
qui peut pas tomber malade mais là quand
j'étais enceinte c'est comme c'est qu'en
plus avec la covid ça c'était vraiment
vraiment le le aussi de contamination de
de peur qu'il va m'arriver quelque chose
puis qu'il va se passer quelque chose
avec le bébé c'était vraiment les jambes
partout là partout partout et même
j'avais peur de boire de l'eau un moment
donné parce que j'étais comme ça qu'il y
a du plomb peut-être que du plomb dans
l'eau c'était comme pas c'était pas
rationnel pas du tout savoir les mains
comme complètement rouge desséché il
était complètement desséché c'était une
purée de ah c'est pas vrai
ils sont partis
avoir des germes partout genre c'est dur
de changer le mindset l'autre fois je
suis dans un avion puis j'ai il y avait
un bébé qui tout ça en arrière puis mets
un bébé c'est un enfant qui tout seul
qui après les trois premiers jours une
grosse un gros une grosse touche genre
dégueu j'ai mal filé là j'avais des
sueurs froides pendant toute le vol puis
fait quand même malade c'est sûr que la
pandémie
on est devenu un peu parano le par
rapport à tout ça mais je pense que ça
va se calmer éventuellement là j'ai revu
des gens aller dans des salles de
concert plein mais c'est super c'est
super pour nous mais c'est vrai que
c'était il a fallu que les gens fassent
filles de ça puis continuent à vivre
ça toi d'arrêter de faire des choses
pendant toute cette période-là
il y a eu plusieurs étapes je pense au
début je pensais pas que ça allait durer
aussi longtemps en fait que j'étais
comme ça
tous endosser le CAM hey oui dans le
fond on va juste fermer toutes deux
semaines
je pense de tes qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ça représentait puis on va dire
c'est les morts on le voyait pas
vraiment au début tu sais c'était comme
c'était assez lointain plus d'un coup ça
s'est rapproché de la maison puis là moi
j'ai commencé à réaliser que ça
commençait à être sérieux
au bout de deux semaines à peu près
parce que au début c'était pas comme
personne c'était clairement personne
puis là j'ai commencé à convive un genre
de petite deuil parce que on vivait un
deuil de notre vie d'avant que moi
quelque chose que je connais pour acquis
qui était de faire des spectacles mais
tout d'un coup ça existait plus
et puis j'en ai suivi bah la
continuation de tout ça
quand c'est ta vie faire des spectacles
puis c'est par ce que j'ai pas là tu
ressens aussi le fruit de ton travail
puis il appréciation du public c'est
beaucoup parlé que ça marche
dans le contexte de la pandémie non plus
même si on voulait être sécuritaire
c'était un peu spécial on vivait pas la
même façon je pense que les gens le
ressentaient aussi d'une autre façon
donc ouais
il y a plus ça et j'ai j'ai trouvé ça
particulier ça a été particulier surtout
pour les gens qui travaillent derrière
la scène dans les coulisses tout ça il y
a eu beaucoup de problèmes de santé
mentale de des personnes qui ont qui ont
souffert énormément de ça c'est c'est
super triste vraiment j'étais pas
c'est de voir justement mon équipe de
prod genre dire ok ben on pourra pas
faire la fin du mois on sait pas ce
qu'on va maintenant de personnes c'est
juste
dans ton entourage proche puis par
extension la mienne qui ont juste décidé
de faire la carrière artistique dans le
fond je vais me réorienter je suis
retourné à l'école puis faire de toi
c'est quand même
c'est toi tu penses tu es en sachant que
quand ça va rep tu vas être une des
premières à repartir tu mettons tu peux
voir qu'il y en a qui ont dû se remettre
en question beaucoup il y en a qui l'ont
fait complètement c'est triste
en informatique ou en admin puis à cette
heure il faut un peu ça
mais je pense que c'était vraiment
quelque chose surtout pour les artistes
de la relève que moi j'ai vu des
artistes de la relève genre commencé
arrêter parce que pandémie puis tout ça
puis devoir repartir recommencer à zéro
il y a rien de plus difficile puis de
perplexe en tout cas pour quelqu'un donc
je pense qu'on a appris beaucoup de tout
ça
est-ce que je le revivrais non pas
nécessairement
le premier EP le lancement était fin
mars
premier vrai show doit présenter nos
affaires comme ça a pas lieu le pied
vient de sortir on peut faire de choses
c'est comme weird finalement ça attise
la suite le métier c'est comme c'est
c'est un timing j'ai trouvé vraiment
courageux c'est ceux qui ont commencé
juste un petit peu avant puis qu'ils
continuent aujourd'hui je pourrais je
suis super impressionné c'est on a
gabouchoir chez bravo c'est que lui
c'était comme son lancement c'était
juste la semaine avant je pense qu'ils
ont que c'est comme la bombe était super
belle lancée ça a été comme coule
vraiment arrêté puis regarde continue le
fait que
ça c'est juste un nom de Tours ceux qui
travaillent en prod de chaud puis petit
les bouquins les salles le casse-tête de
back and furt que eu le de show annulé
de chou- reporté de trouver les dates
les disposes c'est comme ces gens là
c'est les héros
les héros cachés qu'on voit pas mais que
c'est incroyable toutes les cartes qui
ont eu à régler
nous on sait on s'est retrouvé à faire
des shows pendant comme trois ans mais
comme arrêter recommencer arrêtez de
recommencer devant 100 personnes devant
on était un peu perdu dans le
configuration on savait pas où est-ce
qu'on s'en allait moi j'ai fait des
choses qui avaient comme c'est 20
personnes qui après ça tu le lendemain
ton setup pour 20 personnes il faut que
tu le fasses pour 1000 personnes parce
que là dans telle ville il y a pas de
restriction je pourrais j'ai c'était je
pense que pour pour les artistes ça a
été quelque chose de très drainant pour
les équipes de production je parle
vraiment pour tout ce qui est autour je
veux même pas c'était tout un cancer ça
fait pas de bon sens
ou pas à 100%
je pense que beaucoup de modes de
consommation de musique qui ont changé à
cause de la pandémie c'est une ampleur
maintenant avec Tik Tok tu sais que on
n'avait pas avant la pandémie pas du
tout ça change la façon qu'on travaille
la musique je pense que tu es au niveau
des spectacles tout ça c'est comment
quand même un peu rétabli là on est on
est contenter le booking se fait
normalement
on commentait on check les saisons comme
de façon normale le temps de se dire
comme on book genre pour dans cinq ans
c'est au moins ça se fait bien mais
c'est vrai que il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ont changé puis il faut qu'on
s'adapte à ça qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire quand tu parles de Tik
Tok puis la façon avec laquelle on
consomme la musique qui a changé dans
les dans les dernières années c'est
super aléatoire maintenant comme ce qui
va fonctionner ou non si tu regardes on
va dire le top des stream la plupart des
chansons c'est des chansons qui ont eu
un aspect viral
que moi j'aime beaucoup qui est une
artiste française en ce moment il y a
une de ces chansons de 2015 qui traîne
qui est Makeba qui était une super
grosse chanson pour un un super tube que
maintenant c'est comme là
c'est ça c'est super cool pour elle
parce que ça donne une autre vie à son
morceau mais en même temps c'est quoi
les choses c'est comment ça peut arriver
ça je trouve ça vraiment fascinant puis
tu peux pas le prédire l'alchimie
l'alchimie de de ça de qu'est-ce qui
devient viral c'est c'est on dirait
genre de quoi du de l'ésotérisme c'est
comme un petit le gars qui avait fait il
y avait fait du longboard avec la toon
dreams de Fleetwood Mac en buvant du jus
de canneberge mais ça c'est le premier
exemple c'est ça là tu vois ça là tu
fais ok qu'est-ce qui est dans ce
a fait explosé de même ça a quand même
c'est incompréhensible et c'est ça
moi j'adorais ça c'est incroyable mais
c'est ça que des gens qui utilisent ça
aujourd'hui qui disent ok comment ça se
fait que ça ça arrive puis moi j'ai
comme si j'ai commencé aussi à me
pencher à là-dessus moi c'est pas mon
but dans la vie parce que j'ai
comme moi j'ai sorti ma musique à la fin
de l'âge d'or du disque effectivement
ça va super bien mais c'est des fois moi
j'ai des vidéos qui deviennent si ça
devient virale sur mon compte mais il y
a pas de lien il y a pas de il y a pas
de raison c'est genre juste une erreur
dans l'algorithme c'est fou
c'est fou des fois des fois c'est ça les
affaires maintenant que je consomme un
petit peu plus Tik Tok avant les trucs
qui me font si on a eu sur un exemple
d'un extrait de deux filles qui
enregistre justement assis à ta place un
extrait sur l'eau froide je sais pas si
tu l'as vu passer
la chimique fait que ça ça devient le ça
explose à ce point-là
ça faisait comme pas vraiment
d'assurance puis sauf que pourquoi
celui-là c'est tellement parce que c'est
comme un commentaire sur
toute un aspect générationnel
c'est super complexe le pourquoi ça
fonctionne
en tout cas moi je trouve ça fascinant
j'aimerais ça couvrir étudier ça cette
colère c'est surtout le cas de l'eau
froide
pour toi en tant qu'artiste mettons-le
de tirer dans trentaine de fois ok
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est comme
c'est parce que nous on s'est posé cette
question là pour le podcast années de
faire là on va tout savoir l'heure déjà
des des vieux trentenaires qui essaient
d'être cool c'est de faire les mains les
mêmes trains de décès d'embarquer dans
ce sens-là faut trouver sa niche puis
quand tu le trouvais ça marche c'est moi
j'ai j'ai du monde que c'est
spécifiquement des
répertoire avec moi et puis là il
raconte genre des histoires
traumatisantes en faisant leur
maquillage ça c'est comme une niche tu
sais il y a des choses
on l'avait écouté ensemble ce genre une
fille qui se genre un story time plat à
la rencontre le story time c'est une
histoire d'horreur
se maquillant se rappelle tout de suite
de ce que j'ai compris puis ça c'est
quand même complètement c'est spécifique
à Tik Tok puisque c'est vraiment
c'est super c'est ça après ça tu as des
niches comme vraiment super abstraites
de justement des gens qui dansent mais
ça comme un peu c'est un peu mort je
trouve qu'il y a comme plus de monde qui
font ça mais c'est drôle c'est une fois
tu le trouvais mais tu restes là-dedans
puis là les gens ils vont venir te voir
pour ça
que je sais pas c'est quoi ton contenu
TikTok moi curieusement j'ai pas encore
trouvé parce que je suis encore une fois
je suis d'une autre génération fait que
j'essaie de je vais être un peu dans
tout mais ce qui fonctionne le plus
si je me sens mal parce que mais c'est
elle qui me le demande c'est ma fille
qui fait du contenu via mon Tic-Toc
elle elle me demande je suis
comme pourrir remise et je me sens mal
c'est pas je vais pas t'exposer comme ça
mais à l'inceste assez vieille que je
peux
faire
des pauses ça marche beaucoup et non
mais parce que comme un aspect de
comédie qui est expressiblement drôle
puis je me dis peut-être qu'elle va
devenir humoriste plus tard je sais pas
mais à l'heure un délivery avec quelque
chose qui fait que ça fonctionne puis
c'est super attachant puis bon ça c'est
ça mais moi je fais attention tes je
mets tu peux pas sauvegarder mes vidéos
sur Tik Tok parce que je veux pas que
les gens soient gardent les vidéos je
trouve ça juste bizarre il y a des trucs
que tu peux faire pour que ça soit
sécuritaire dans le fond
bref c'est mon petit cours sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que tu sais tu as
quand même vu
le ledscape changé pitié le milieu de la
musique comme tu disais suis arrivé à la
fin des disques
arrivé oui
je me souviens que ton premier disque
était matériel qui est partout là
[Musique]
[Rires]
super belle voiture mais non c'est c'est
qui existe plus d'ailleurs
malheureusement
puis je suis contente et j'en ai vendu
comme beaucoup fait que j'étais vraiment
chanceuse d'avoir pu bénéficier de ça
maintenant c'est pour un jeune artiste
c'est que vraiment compliqué c'est les
revenus se font vraiment viole live tu
sais donc c'est pour ça que la pandémie
ça a été encore plus triste parce que
c'est chaud mais c'est vrai que ouais
moi j'ai connu ça après ça j'ai connu
genre le digital après ça le streaming
est arrivé il était comme une autre
c'était autre chose
donc il faut s'adapter c'est quand même
assez complexe ça nous demande d'être
toujours un peu comme à l'affût de comme
qu'est-ce qui se passe
que j'ai complètement rejeté comme beewy
Hills comme nom je veux pas aller là
tu trouves ton truc qui fonctionne mais
tu l'utilises puis tu essaie de trouver
ta femme là
tu fais ça puis le nombre de phases
qu'il y a eu il y en a eu beaucoup à 15
ans il y a eu le disque après ça c'était
comme les MP3 mais iTunes avec une star
puis après ça le style l'important tes
réseaux sociaux c'est comme
des adaptations plusieurs
que pour un artiste que c'est vraiment
pas son bail puisque ça il tombe
vraiment pas mais c'est quand même un
défi puis
j'étais on essaie de travailler aussi
avec les artistes que chez bravo c'est
comme nous on peut t'aider tout ça me
fait plaisir mais c'est vrai qu'il y en
a que c'est vraiment pas leur truc fait
que ça c'est comme un quelque chose en
plastique il faut que tu fasses puis que
maintenant il faut que tu sois ton
propre comme une manager il faut que je
fasse tes propres affaires tout seul
donc
ouais t'as pas vraiment un choix à moins
que tu sois genre une des plus grosses
grosses stars tu as pas le choix de de
construire ta communauté sur les réseaux
sociaux maintenant c'est fou quand même
sans développement
même si tu aurais pas nécessairement à
le faire pour ta carrière à toi faut
quand même que tu restes fut pour la
gagne chez bravo dans le fond absolument
parce que toi c'est ça aussi le matin la
dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé pour de
vrai tu venais de prendre possession la
boîte comment ça se passe ça va super
bien c'est sûr que bon pour ajouter à
vos éléments de défi dans ma vie j'étais
j'ai racheté
l'ancienne boîte pour faire bravo comme
au milieu de la pandémie si on avait
comme pas spectacle on avait rien prévu
c'était vraiment très très
déstabilisant puis quand tu te lances en
entrepreneuriat ce que j'ai fait ben
c'est c'est des hôpitaux il y a une
acquisition donc évidemment il y a des
gens qui sont partis il y a des gens qui
sont arrivés
c'est un ça reste quelque chose d'assez
intense pour une entreprise de se faire
racheter effectivement j'étais je
voulais juste genre que tout le monde se
sent bien
puis pour vrai jusqu'à présent ça va
extrêmement bien je suis pas contente il
y a vraiment une croissance au sein de
la compagnie qui est incroyable les gens
sont bien moi j'ai une approche un peu
comme plus se centrer sur l'artiste donc
c'est les artistes se sont bien aussi
les artistes sont pas contents mais ils
peuvent le dire puis
je pense que
comme une gestionnaire qui a du sens
mais je sais pas mon travail non plus
mon travail c'est d'être artiste puis de
faire de la DA dans le fond parce que je
fais beaucoup de direction artistique
mais je suis pas gestionnaire
fait que j'ai une équipe avec moi
c'est quand même cool j'ai une équipe de
direction qui est incroyable victime
même si moi la fin qui dit oui je suis
quand même des gens qui prennent pas mal
de décisions
on est 25 employés à peu près
genre catalogue de plusieurs de
centaines c'est de petit d'artistes
il y a peut-être un petit peu plus mais
c'est beaucoup mieux c'est beaucoup
quand même
ça a été quoi le
top français en fait derrière cette
décision là parce que c'est une grosse
décision là-dessus de c'est pour toi
lifeting de dire ok mais là je
m'embarque dans cette aventure là
j'imagine une décision de coeur
financièrement mettons mettons que du
point de vue strictement business ça
fait du sens avoir les balles en 2023 ou
c'est strictement de faire de
tout ça est arrivé
mon premier ma première pensée était ok
si l'ancien propriétaire va à qui que ce
soit d'autre
les employés les artistes
tout le monde qui est en périphérie dans
le fond vont se retrouver dans les mains
d'une autre entreprise ou d'une autre
personne qui a peut-être
par rapport ou que tu connais pas le
catalogue ou qui est juste
là pour faire son business et puis c'est
correct aussi ça aurait pu être ça moi
j'aurais pu prendre mon argent pour
suivre tout le monde puis m'en aller
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu faire ça je non
mais j'avais les moyens de faire puis ça
aurait été facile pour moi de le faire
mais
c'est jamais vraiment facile par exemple
moi dans ma position j'aurais pu le
faire parce que de toute façon c'est mon
contrôle était je j'aurais pu trouver
des façons de me sortir de ça mais c'est
pas le cas pour les autres artistes donc
j'ai décidé de faire une offre parce que
je pouvais le faire j'étais dans une
position je pouvais le faire puis on me
dit oui
et au moment où on m'a dit oui mais là
je me ça a été quand même très long
processus évidemment parce que c'est
quand même très longue les langues
étaient sur plusieurs mois
je me suis retrouvé à la avec un les
Bott mais j'ai pas moi qui ont dit oui
tout de suite ok
stressé un petit peu parce que je
représenterait quand même un gros
pourcentage de
savoir personne si je vais capable que
l'accompagner soit rentable puis
profitable bref j'étais un peu j'étais
un peu stressée par rapport à tout ça
mais finalement
quand c'est arrivé je pense que ça a été
le meilleur
outcom dans le fond
juste parce que j'ai gardé ça
indépendant et genre j'ai eu des gens
qui m'ont approché par la suite et de
d'autres entreprises qui ont fait ce
qu'on peut genre venir t'aider et puis
moi j'ai dit non parce que je pense que
c'est important de rester indépendant
c'est pour ça que moi j'avais signé là
parce que il y a un côté un peu punk
puis un côté un peu genre on n'a pas
besoin d'être de personnes puis je
trouvais ça cool c'est pour les artistes
surtout qui est pas d'autres entités
d'autres gens qui viennent se maigrir
des affaires du la maison de disque et
puis je continue là-dedans ouais c'est
une manière aussi pour toi de de
pandémie justement le choc de hockey il
y a rien qui est certain dans le fond du
jour au lendemain je peux ne plus faire
de choses puis toi qui est germaphobe
aussi puis
non mais dans le sens que tu es chez toi
de la part de tomber malade aussi puis
de la voix tout seul c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est fragile fait que
d'avoir ça qui arrive de quoi peu
importe mettons whatever x je peux plus
faire de chaud mais au moins j'ai ça
c'est comme un genre de truc non parce
que là c'est fait
on a beaucoup
pour que les artistes en développement
puissent
continuer à vivre leur vie puis à
devenir des super grands artistes
éventuellement moi il faut que je
continue à faire des choses
donc c'est pas moi je suis contente ça
me fait du bien c'est juste que il y a
beaucoup d'investissement de ma personne
puis de mon temps parce que toutes les
plans mais je fais ça pour le le bien la
continuation de la musique en français
puis la culture québécoise certaines
façons quand tu dis que
toi
tantôt quand tu parlais d'avoir la
pression quand tu fais les choses de la
pression des des musiciens des gens de
la pression encore plus grande de faire
des choses il faut pas que tu tombes
malade
mais ça doit être le fun quand même de
pouvoir
transmettre ton ton apprentissage ton
savoir à des artistes plus jeunes avant
avant
pas tout le temps des conseils en fait
mon mon ma façon de fonctionner c'est je
vais te donner des conseils tu les
prends tu les prends pas ou tu prends
des des parties de tous ça tombe mais
jamais j'impose quoi que ce soit sur qui
ce soit le des gens qui veulent faire
leur pochette de 10 tout seul moi je
suis comme s'il y a pas de problème
tu sais c'est pas
on est là puis on guide dans le fond
dans
ta carrière maintenant je veux juste
essayer de spécifier ma question l'autre
jour j'étais allé courir avec un de nos
amis du secondaire
moi je pense tu sais j'ai je pense j'ai
pas j'ai de quoi comme j'ai échoué ma
vie ou si je me suis pas rendu où est-ce
que je voulais juste regarder je fais de
même genre
ça commence là tu dis oui on est dans 30
ans mais ça la vie commence en haut toi
par rapport à ta carrière toi tu
l’impression que tu es comme au début tu
es une vétérante et comment tu te vois
comment tu sens que les autres de voix
j'ai commencé très jeune donc c'est sûr
que j'ai quand même c'est ça j'ai 15 ans
à peu près de vécu de carrière c'est sûr
que j'ai vécu des très très gros hall
des gros pic au début
quand j'avais genre 25 26 ans aussi
c'était quand même assez artiste
pour les gens autour de moi c'était
quand même intense
je sais pas je sais pas où est-ce que je
me suis je pense que j'ai je suis dans
le en ce moment je suis dans une phase
un peu plus calme
parce que j'ai vécu des choses c'est
justement avec l'acquisition c'est avoir
la compagnie
c'est une autre sorte de carrière qui
t'a débuté pour moi
ça prend du temps
ça me demande si je pense que ma fille
remis je lis pas eu beaucoup parce que
je faisais tellement tourné puis je les
ai pas eu beaucoup c'est juste qu'il y a
plein de parties où j'ai pas été là pour
elle puis je veux pas vivre ça avec mon
fils puis pour elle non plus pour
remonter j'ai envie de faire partie de
tout le temps là l'autre c'est d'être
Lucie à l'autre besoin c'est sûr que
quand il y a des bouts qu'il faut que je
parte en tournée c'est ils vont
comprendre là mais Arlo je sais de
l'amener le plus que je peux ça a été
assez demandant quand il était petit
parce que je l'amenais puis il y avait 4
mois puis j'avais je dormais pas puis je
faisais mes chou pareil mais maintenant
j'essaie de voir ce différemment je
pense que il y a une façon de penser la
carrière
qui soit aussi en lien avec
leur vie
il y a des gens qui choisissent de comme
Papa leurs enfants puis de travailler
puis sauf que les moments qu'on a là en
ce moment avec eux c'est maintenant
ouais
une période justement de faire moins de
choses mais les choisir qui compte là
aussi j'ai ce luxe là avec la pandémie
on a dû faire refaire beaucoup de choses
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
pitié des fois je me disais c'est je
comprends parce qu'on est dans un
contexte un peu spécial mais je faisais
beaucoup trop de show pour qu'est-ce que
je devais faire on va dire pour comme ça
ça enlevé de la l'importance à ce que je
faisais aussi je pense qu'il faut juste
repenser un petit peu la tournée puis
je pense que je suis rendu j'ai vraiment
ce privilège là dans le fond rendu au
stade de ma carrière
tu as fait un album de piano solo une
chose que première fois que tu faisais
un album aussi de musique de de jeux
vidéo ouais ça a été quoi en fait la
décision derrière ça le DH j'ai goût
d'essayer ça il y a tellement tourné
dans mon short
en plus j'ai que je pense je t'avais
écrit pour mon ami qui a une auberge à
Notre-Dame du portage et puis quand tu
descends en bas du fleuve je l'ai écouté
tellement souvent en descendant en plus
remis au camp des vacances puis je je
suis rapide aussi
mais oui non
salut l'auberge sur moi parce que je
menais de me faire opérer puis j'avais
pas le droit de rien faire je peux pas
parler je pouvais pas j'étais comme un
convalescence c'est vraiment pas chelou
je me suis enfermée dans mon studio puis
j'ai juste fait ça pendant une semaine
puis c'était finalement comme ce que
j'entendais dans ma tête c'est qu'il
fallait que je traduise en piano fallait
que je crée de toute façon puis j'ai
trouvé ça très très fun comme exercice
après est-ce que c'est le piano le plus
fou est-ce que c'est du rack Magnin 9
non mais ça reste quand même ce coeur de
Pirate mais en piano
a été pas composé et enregistrer une
semaine
de toute façon pour pour Coeur de Pirate
l'autre c'est juste ça une mélodie dans
ma tête que je transpose c'est au piano
je fais des arrangements après ça
commence comme ça c'est est-ce que tu
sais toujours comme ça
non jamais c'est oui ou non
c'était comme m'y attendait les mélodies
dans sa tête aussi transposer pour
toutes les instruments puis j'ai fait ça
avec aussi quand j'ai fait la musique du
c'est quand j'allais travailler à
l'oreille c'est souvent comme ça
trop au piano
mais je pense que c'est quand même comme
un enfant surtout quand tu es vraiment
quand les gens ils travaillent à
l'oreille c'est vraiment beaucoup ça ou
je chantais comme un peu n'importe quoi
à peu près se trouver les mots dessus
parce que c'est quasiment plus fréquent
je pense que d'écrire puis après ça je
me rends compte plus on reçoit des
artistes
des fois oui ça dépend est-ce que tu en
as beaucoup de maladies dans ta tête
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas écrit de
chanson puis je trouve ça un peu bizarre
parce que j'ai comme les syndrome de la
page
pas dans un espace créatif
[Rires]
j'ai pas eu c'est vrai j'ai pas j'ai pas
écrit depuis un petit bout c'est oui
mais je vais remédier à ça bientôt mais
parce que j'ai beaucoup de pression
autre de corporate
c'est c'est un peu anticatif de d'être
entrepreneur j'ai l'impression que c'est
comme ça que je le vis là c'est une
autre type de création mais c'est dur de
libre c'est de faire un peu ce que tu
veux je suis un peu la danse moi je me
questionne beaucoup mais mais non non ça
va revenir
de concept de son dans ta tête ou
vraiment comme c'est tout est possible
tout
[Musique]
de pirate mais c'est vrai que j'ai pensé
à faire autre chose un petit peu ou de
transposer quelqu'un musical dans ce que
je fais dans la pop et que les gens
feraient comme ah ouais c'est pas
qu'elle irait le mais l'album
genre beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes qui font des covers de threed
is Grace pourquoi beaucoup mais genre
parce que j'en ai écouté un une fois au
complet le TOC là c'est le plus grand
fan depuis des grace et l'histoire
l'humanité puis là c'est juste
qu'il faut c'est que tu découvres plein
de talents
peux-tu dire comment tu te montres
cohabiter sur une planète je sais pas
les prochaines
mais c'est l'évolution de la langue
française au final disons-le maintenant
je suis folle je suis encore en anglais
en français chacun en français j'ai fait
un peu en anglais il y a un bon mais
j'ai pas réussi
de voir si ça prend un en anglais non
mais en fait j'avais signé chez les
balles j'avais signé chez
les boss s'est fait du Sud c'était chez
intersco puis mon dropis avec ça j'ai
fait ok bon
je ne suis pas aussi importante que je
le pensais donc je vais je vais passer à
autre chose donnant mais c'était
vraiment c'était un peu triste à
l'époque là et en plus genre en allais
sur une tournée au States j'étais un peu
stressé mais non non c'est c'est j'ai
appris lecture moi j'ai fait des tonnes
en anglais parce que je travaillais
surtout avec des producteurs à l'époque
qui était anglophones ou suédois
qui je me disais je me suis dit pourquoi
pas faire des tours en anglais mais
c'est pas il y avait pas de
de ta part vraiment beaucoup ces
chansons là en plus
je parlais tantôt ça m'a frappé juste
avant qu'on enregistre tu parlais du
spectacle pour le festival d'été qui
s'en vient plus tard cette semaine les
gens qui vont écouter le podcast
on s'arrête ça a été incroyable il
faisait soleil
dans deux semaines seulement la semaine
prochaine
c'est sûr ça sortira pas avant jeudi
mais ça va être un spectacle incroyable
au soleil les critiques sont
là c'est le seul mot qu'on met après
critique des critiques du terrain avec
mais tu disais que tu étais comme un peu
nerveuse parce que là tu disais on a
déjà assez pratiqué tu sais je suis
prête pour le chaud puis je me disais
si toi tu dis ça maintenant après 15 ans
de carrière puis des chevaux absorbent
ça s'en va jamais dans le
fonds
que tu recommences parce que parce que
c'est
il faut toujours que ton premier mot
puis une fois que ton premier mot ça
porte tout seul pour les gens qui font
de la musique qui vont comprendre ce que
je veux dire c'est si je t'appelle de
ton premier mot pour le reste du couplet
Théo qui même après tant d'années ça
m'arrive des fois d'avoir très peur de
ça alors que c'est que la musique c'est
géré par une autre partie de ton cerveau
là c'est pour ça que les gens qui ont
besoin
que tu es capable de chanter n'importe
quel chanson de je sais pas bien connaît
du tout puisque
je connais des c'est ça c'est une un des
plus grandes mystères de la ville des
fois j'ai oublié la date de fête de mon
père tu sais mais je me rappelle à tout
jamais
de toutes les tonnes d'ici toutes les
tonnes d'ici au complet je connais
toutes les parts des fois que mettons
qu'on écoutait au secondaire
mettons que j'ai jamais réécouté en 15
ans je l'écoute puis je suis pas encore
la chanter
c'est d'oublier tes paroles ouais ouais
puis
ça m'est arrivé une seule fois comme
vraiment genre majeur que j'ai comme
j'ai eu un blanc total puis juste
incapable de recommencer la chanson
c'était
humilialiste en Autriche je pense que ça
se trouve sur Internet
les gens qui vont voir au concert ils
vont comprendre
c'est comme quand
c'est comme plus déstresser plus ça
arrive moins tu es stressé moins sérieux
mais j'imagine que des affaires comme ça
ça arrive c'est ça arrive tout le temps
tout le monde je pense que ça arrive à
tout le monde puis les gens vont
commencer ils ont genre manger leurs
mots à tel endroit il y a dû oublier ces
paroles
puis
il y a ce qui fait
puis il a commencé les deux printemps
puis là il y a comme son guitariste son
Bessa qui sont regardés ils ont regardé
dans map il était comme qu'est-ce qu'on
est en train de faire embarqué
finalement dans ton puis après la tonne
d'aller manger regardez genre sur cette
liste puis est faite en passant juste on
va la faire
tout le temps
c'est oui ça arrive tout le temps
j'y ai pensé aussi
un certain âge je pense que c'est
je sais pas combien d'années d'albums
tu ressors une tonne deuxième album que
tu as pas fait depuis 20 ans
dans les derniers shows qui faisaient ce
que ma mère m'a dit
c'est possible
chanson sur ton site
tu peux lui dire
qu'il y avait des trompettes
il y a un saxophone genre un
plus gros encore
c'est le plus gros c'est comme ça
[Musique]
mais non non mais oui c'est vrai
regroupement du Québec et comme on va
partager ça
maintenant c'est ça c'est fait que des
basses on fait comme des chansons que
j'ai pas faites depuis extrêmement
longtemps je pense qu'il y avait une
chanson que j'avais pas joué depuis
pour les gens qui sont vraiment fans
puis qui sont comme ils peuvent plus
mais vraiment important
oui non avec ses chansons sont prises
avec des chansons surprises des fois que
les gens ils deviennent fous là les
femmes étaient le Swift c'est un autre
affaire là
que ça devait être de même pour les
Beatles
c'est le fun de pouvoir faire vivre ses
émotions-là
il y avait quelqu'un un jour tu es le
Swift était comme un genre de Vox Pop là
je sais pas trop mais genre la personne
s'était mise en service
je sais pas je me dis c'est c'est ça
qu'il faut comme ça qu'il faut vivre la
vie on dirait que c'est ce truc c'est
meilleur posture que de partir prendre
un genre
et l'affaire puis que genre tout le
monde capote j'ai quand même vécu des
déceptions professionnelles dans ma vie
aussi là fait que tu es des fois tu
arrives tu dis ah oui d'accord je vais
tout gagner
des choses comme ça ou genre tu vas
faire un spectacle le spectacle
finalement c'est comme les billets ils
ont pas vraiment super bien vendu ça
arrive là ça c'est complètement la
réalité absolument
la pandémie si j'ai fait des spectacles
quand j'étais enceinte puis c'était
comme des salles en France ou
c'était des salles de théâtre de ville
dans le fond
puis à cause de la pandémie ben tiens il
y avait des billets des gens qui
venaient pas effectivement
80% ou genre 100% de la salle mais tu
avais tu avais plein de difficultés de
sièges vides parce que les gens ils
viennent pas parce que soit qu'il y
avait peur ou qui qui voulait le
spectacle a été décalé genre 6 fois avec
le
il venait pas donc ça c'est sûr que tu
arrives direct tu tombes tu viens de
Montréal puis le temps arrive à ta salle
puis il y a moins de gens prévus fait
que c'est ça fait toujours un petit
mais
ça va c'est je pense que je les faisais
quand même chaud puis j'étais contente
puis mais c'est vrai que c'était des
fois ça c'était
une salle une sale ville pendant que ça
devait être du stock là quand il y avait
genre
10% de la du monde qui de la salle tout
le monde le vécu là mais c'était
vraiment c'était
public off tu sais c'est qui c'est le
dire que le public qui fait partie du
show mais c'est vraiment vrai parce que
plus le public te donne l'énergie plus
c'est facile d'en donner puis c'est
comme on se lève vers le haut de mon
enfant mais quand un public qui est
Rohff c'est comme ça peut être
[Rires]
c'était vraiment drôle parce que moi
j'ai commencé à fonctionner un petit peu
mieux en Europe puis en Europe il y a
plus de monde évidemment ton setting de
festival ben c'est sûr qu'il va mille
personnes même si tu joues à une heure
de l'après-midi en gros c'est ça le
tarif le j'avais ça je faisais la
tournée du Rosec ce qui est comme
vraiment des tout petit sacs c'est super
cute c'est vraiment genre comme tout le
monde est assis puis j'étais
toute seule
j'avais comme un genre de
gros décalage mais ça me ramenait
vraiment à terre
au début de ma carrière en France on
faisait des super gros sales mais on
n'avait pas l'argent encore pour se
déplacer comment tourbus ou des choses
comme ça fait qu'on était en van mettez
on faisait des salles de Jean 3000 parce
que c'était juste j'ai juste vécu ça moi
des écarts
ce que ça devait être qu'est-ce que ça
pouvait être puis
c'est pas grave c'est juste que je pense
que ça me garder déconnecter de ce qui
se passait pour de vrai effectivement ce
que je voyais c'était le top iTunes
parce qu'à l'époque c'était le top et
pour voir si ça fonctionnait ou non
fun sauf que j'étais en vanne puis on se
l'avait pas ça sent la marde de Toto
c'est l'histoire c'est l'histoire
poétique du musicien
c'est tout le temps moins glam qui ont
pensé mais je pense que ça je pense
honnêtement que c'est pour tout ce que
tu viens de dire là c'est tout le temps
que tu penses que c'est j'adore les gens
qui sont tournés en France c'est comme
c'est fou tu sais ça donne comme des
vacances puis moi je suis genre en train
de me laver les cheveux dans un évier
aujourd'hui des potes en festival puis
tu as pas de facilité tu es comme avec
plein de monde dans une tente
de katering c'est pas tout le temps des
consulter incroyable des fois c'est
vraiment fou
sont quand même great pour ceux
mais je pense c'est vraiment super cher
[Rires]
on va essayer
je t'avais posé une question si tu veux
pas parler de ça on en parle pas puis je
sais pas si on coupe reste extrait on
avait parlé de la tonne
côté pour faire ça
a été réutilisé récemment là dans une
chanson de diplôme je sais plus je sais
plus
donc
vu que j'ai pas c'est pas toi la chanson
en fait c'est comme il y a pas besoin de
me demander mais tu me le dis je te dis
je sais pas je suis cool
on avait sorti un pays aussi
sous un affaire qui s'appelait armistice
pour les gens qui se rappellent livrer
au gif ferme de cœur de pirate
on avait fait ça avec Mariah care Browns
un peu un album western
c'est c'est vraiment agréable
comment tu vis ça à être dans le public
dans le mettons mais
dans le sens que tu sais que je sais pas
un nouveau chat il va avoir un séjour
qui va en parler si toutes ces affaires
là
ça ça gosse dans le fond mais est-ce que
c'est gosse
[Rires]
journaliste dans le fond
parce que je vis comme deux côtés tout
ça dans le sens que au Québec les gens
connaissent en France et je me
connaissent mais dans le monde
anglophone les gens me connaissent pas
du tout
moi j'avais dans l'ouest de la ville
l'ouest de la ville est principalement
Englos
c'était conscient ou juste j'aime ça
j'aime ça mon coin de jeu je le trouve
beau mais mais c'est fascinant parce que
personne sait qui je suis comme pendant
longtemps mon voisin pensait que c'était
la maison de mes parents ah ouais c'est
bon
chalet dans le monde francophone on va
dire la région dans une autre région
complètement
c'est mon projet c'est un projet
je voulais en parler justement
de la place
salut tout le monde
c'est là allô
[Rires]
j'oublie j'oublie juste qui je suis des
fois
de deux mondes là
je vais à mon chalet plus je me sens
vraiment aimé
incroyable c'était dessus c'était dessus
l'appel de la nature le chalet c'est
aussi le syndrome de la page blanche je
me suis dit qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour remédier au syndrome de la page
blanche
les insectes
jamais eu de chalet dans la vie c'était
un peu confronté à la nature une fois
que tu en as un moi j'ai grandi en ville
ça fait que j'étais comme
ah qu'est-ce qui peut bien arriver dans
un chalet mais les bébés c'est vraiment
ça peut vraiment être chiant ça peut
ruiner des vacances pour eux c'est
quelque chose j'ai je pense investir
dans un soute moustiquaire
pour aller oui
c'est ça
tu avais envie de t'éloigner de la ville
mes parents ils ont un condo dans cette
coin-là aussi effectivement
avec eux puis tu penses profiter de la
nature c'est le fun parce que c'est
comme un entre les deux je peux
complément dans le bois je suis un petit
peu en ville c'est parfait j'adore ça
j'adore ça puis YouTube des travaux à
faire
un shooter
puis finalement on l'a eu très
rapidement plus je sais comme ah ouais
les gens ils veulent voir ça mais c'est
c'est je veux que les gens pensent
vraiment je veux vraiment qu'il pense ça
parce que c'est c'est pas ça c'est c'est
pas ça du tout ça va être quoi c'est
pour les gens qui me connaissent un
petit peu
je sais pas je suis pas très manuel dans
la vie de la comédie dans le fond c'est
toi qui essaie de réparer les choses
c'est pas ta moi des fois moi c'est un
peu abstrait
mais il se passe plein d'affaires parce
que justement je sais j'ai jamais fait
ça puis là le chalet est magnifique
c'est une structure magnifique mais il y
a énormément de surprises de
savais pas ouais ça gosse la chose qui
gosse ça gosse voilà mais il y a rien
qui arrive pour rien on va faire une
mission de télépile parce que c'est je
pense que ça me permet de montrer notre
facette de moi les gens ils pensent que
je suis comme full triste puis que je
pars dans un coin tout le temps
mais j'ai quand même drôle
on va montrer un peu ce côté là un faux
documentaire si tu as un faux
documentaire de rénovation c'est juste
un faux documentaire que vous allez
genre faire ça joue beaucoup sur la
ligne si je pense que les gens ils vont
ils vont le regarder premier épisode ils
vont faire comme ok Agnès Agnès un peu
ça se voit parce que si c'est pas ça la
lecture que les gens ont qui font 2
semaines
[Rires]
j'ai déjà ils savent pas mais si vous
êtes sur Reddit sur le bord de causerie
je suis là
quelqu'un
qui a comme faire des fois
c'est pour ça des choses rénaux puis je
dis à ça oui c'est exactement pour ça
fait que
on salue user 1 2 4 7 8 9 tu le connais
par cœur
dans ta cuisine sur mon bord de
projection il est juste là
[Musique]
vous allez vraiment profond j'ai pas du
tout réfléchi à ça
c'était de la musique de films
là c'est sûr que j'aimerais ça pouvoir
avoir un artiste qui serait un calibre
assez important que je puisse épauler
cet artiste là
c'est comme comme un manager ou quelque
chose comme ça à son plein potentiel
sinon un peu comme Mario puis les deux
frères
mais oui
sinon je me dis je sais pas j'aimerais
ça comme peut-être faire autre chose que
de la musique c'est comme projetée dans
d'autres asper j'essaie de le faire avec
justement cette émission de rénovation
qui
[Musique]
mais on y est mais mettons jouer
mettons-nous dans un film je pense que
j'ai trop j'ai passé de filtres pour
être vraiment comédienne à 100%
c'est pas un rêve que tu
d'exister puis de continuer à faire de
la musique comme je peux puis surtout
perdurer tu as envie que les gens ils se
souviennent de toi puis que
mais d'une autre façon peut-être pas
juste en tant que pirate c'est ça puis
là maintenant je reviens à ton objectif
avant qui était de des problèmes
artistes dans une carrière
tellement
tu es à la recherche un peu de temps
directrice de les balles trouver le
j'aimerais bien la personne qui qui peut
défoncer toute l'étude mais parce que
idéalement moi je ferai plus de
spectacle c'est je c'est ça mon but
c'est de plus genre de chose à un moment
donné je trouve que il faut laisser la
place
à la relève aux jeunes aux gens qui
veulent faire la musique sinon c'est je
me vois mal faire des spectacles encore
une tournée genre à 65 ans parce que
déjà je je suis un peu fatiguée j'ai
fait ça depuis j'ai 18 ans puis je suis
extrêmement asthmatique aussi les gens
ils savent pas mais je regarde tout à la
caméra
mais si je prends les pauvres entre les
gens c'est des fois je pars à courir je
vais prendre ma pompe puis je reviens je
pourrais
en plus récemment c'est pour recalibrer
à quel point tu es asthmatique
pneumologue était quand même écris
mais en tout cas c'est tout ça pour dire
que c'est beaucoup de gestion donc
j'aimerais ça éventuellement te laisser
la place aux jeunes puis c'est important
de laisser la place aussi de pas pour
rester un peu trop dans le décor c'est
pour ça que je veux travailler derrière
idéalement amener quelqu'un au stade de
Coeur de Pirate c'est pas plus
mais c'est pas quelque chose que tu
penses que tu vas t'ennuyer si tu dis
que tu veux laisser la place à amener je
comprends que je comprends qu'on tient
amené toutefois son temps puis
il y a la fatigue qui s'accumule puis
c'est chose là mais il y a quand même
moins ça va paraître quand même grisant
puis quelque chose de super
gratifiant de faire des spectacles des
trucs comme ça tu penses pas que c'est
quelque chose que tu vas incroyable pour
vrai c'est pour vrai c'est un c'est un
superbe moment moi je vis beaucoup
d'émotions quand je fais des spectacles
aussi mais c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
extrêmement
drainant quand tu fais une tournée c'est
pas tant un show qui est drainant c'est
quand ça fait une tournée de je sais pas
combien de spectacles pendant trois
semaines qui étaient pas chez vous que
tu es sur le décalage que tu dors très
peu moi je dors très mal en en
déplacement aussi là en avion tout ça je
dors juste pas là fait que c'était je
faisais des choses sur trois heures de
sommeil
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon pour ton
mental c'est bon tes cordes vocales donc
oui j'ai toutes les côtés incroyables du
hide du spectacle c'est fou mais ça joue
sur ton mental au long terme
pour tout le monde c'est pas juste moi
c'est tout le monde
est-ce que
je sais pas comment poser cette question
là
parce que moi des fois j'ai l'impression
puis je vais repartir de moi puis
j'apprécie
plus grande
j'ai l'impression des fois mettons qu'un
qui a beaucoup beaucoup d'affaires qui
se passe puis tout à l'heure de
quelqu'un en ce moment qui est beaucoup
à faire qui se passe-t-il beaucoup de
gros affaires qui demandent nécessaire
beaucoup de gestion mais j'ai
l'impression des fois de courir après ma
queue en ce moment je suis dans un je
suis dans ce dans ce moment-là où est-ce
que là j'ai l'impression que je cours
après quelque chose que je regarde
rattraper puis genre je suis je me
réveille essoufflé maintenant est-ce que
tu as ce feeling là des fois puis est-ce
que tu trouves ça pique comment tu le
gères si tu le ouais je l'ai eu la
dernière tournée que j'ai faite en
Europe parce qu'on avait tellement de
report tellement de trucs de spectacle
qui revenaient que je pourrais j'étais
allé à reculons dans cette tournée là
parce que ma santé mentale était pas top
top je pense que je vivais un genre de
dépression passe-partum tu sais faire là
ça ça me drainé beaucoup à ce moment-là
un moment donné j'ai pris mon bip ça
allait mais c'est vrai que je pense que
l'important quand tu te sens un peu
overwhereum qui a trop de choses c'est
un trouble d'adaptation le burn-out là
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle ça
il faut que tu vois une journée à la
fois puis tes tâches dans ta journée
puis tu projettes pas trop dans le futur
parce que c'est là que l'anxiété revient
fait je sais que c'est plus dur à faire
est-ce que tu le fais des fois parce que
vraiment comme activement
faire ok une liste de ça aujourd'hui
puis chaque tâche comme tel est une mini
torche c'est moins on veut un mec mais
tu le fais dessus comme physiquement
faire écrire des trucs à faire mais là
j'essaie de plus me projeter c'est fini
c'est fini tu as réussi à battre ça
complètement ben non des fois ça revient
ça revient comme ça salut mais mais non
non c'est c'est super important de
d'aller jour au jour le jour puis
c'était des fois même si ça devient
intense de voir des tâches dans la
journée comme oh est-ce que je vais être
capable parce que je vais arriver à
temps mais c'est enfin le même principe
que les gens qui ont des problèmes
d'addiction c'est
ce que je fais aujourd'hui puis c'est
juste ça qui compte après ça on va
commencer à te projeter dans dans la
situation aussi tu pourrais consommer le
ton là
c'est ça mais c'est le même principe
c'est comme hors de ton contrôle ça veut
dire que c'est même principe que quand
tu es dans une file puis tu attends puis
c'est long faut juste que tu fasses
comme
ça je peux pas faire plus que ce qui est
là en ce moment ça c'est ça demande
beaucoup de
force mentale
patience dans le trafic de Montréal
actuellement je suis souvent là dessus
souvent
de vouloir m'en aller je suis en train
de prendre une heure de plus que ça me
prendrait si je le faisais de nuit
n'essayer de pas être en tabarnak
essayez de rester relax dans le moment
écoutez je suis fier de pirate
écoute personnel
dans le trafic mettons une fois que tu
es dedans
[Musique]
on va dire
mais non mais je sais pas je pense c'est
une question que je me posais parce que
je suis je suis à ce spot là
je l'ai maintenant et voilà ouais
tu avais parlé quand
sorti persil justement tu avais dit que
tu avais c'était à écouter en écoutant
bigle live la série
en pleurant en regardant en Californie
quand il pleut c'est ça
parce que tu as écouté ça puis tu as
fait genre
ça me faisait penser à une trame sonore
c'est vraiment juste quelque chose pour
accompagner
vos sentiments qui n'ont pas de mots
voilà
la musique comme ça de film de trame
sonore
c'est quelque chose qui est juste un
travail à temps plein
activement resolé pour ça avoir un agent
c'est vraiment comme travailler dans
cette lignée là des fois où ça m'est
arrivé c'était vraiment juste parce que
c'est arrivé qui me voulait moi c'est
mais sinon
c'est vraiment un gros travail de
d'argent
souvent mettons une période pour le
faire puis le deadline est quand même
vraiment court fait que quand tu es
dedans c'est comme il faut que tu pondes
un score au complet vraiment rapidement
[Musique]
au début de l'année ça m'a mon premier
ma première musique de film complet ça
va tomber dans janvier février que
j'avais comme pas vraiment de chaud
pendant d'autres affaires j'ai pu le
faire c'était malade mais j'étais comme
ça tombé genre maintenant qui comme
disait j'ai besoin d'un score pour dans
deux mois en ce moment avec toutes les
autres trucs c'est comme impossible
c'est comme j'ai l'impression que le
monde qui font ça ils font ça
le bruit
c'est comme on dirait que c'est c'est un
métier c'est top de
faire ça puis en ayant une maison de
disque en faisant des chevaux en ayant
tout quelque chose
qui est encore une fois
avance toi pas si ça tente pas mais de
tes artistes à bravo c'est les quelques
en ce moment tu aimes vraiment beaucoup
mais j'aime tout le monde non mais c'est
que tu veux que les gens découvrent que
tu penses mais ok je vais te donner une
autre question qui va être facile
ceux que tu crois que les gens
gagneraient à découvrir plus maintenant
actuellement et pour la culture au
Québec
parce qu'on en a pas vraiment je pense
que Naomi c'est vraiment un exemple clé
de une artiste qu'on devrait faire
monter mousser parce que
c'est quand même assez la diversité on
en a au Québec c'est comme parce que
c'est très blanc c'est plate c'est très
correct mais pendant longtemps ça a été
ça puis là je pense que c'est important
justement d'avoir un peu de diversité
parce que ça va faire qu'après ça il y a
d'autres gens qui vont se retrouver dans
cet artiste là qui vont se dire ah ok
ben moi aussi je peux je peux faire ça
sinon
la représente aussi un nouveau nouveau
son
pour vrai il y avait un trou de pour le
rugby pour la pop qui est un peu teintée
de ça ouais il y en avait il y en avait
un mais je veux dire c'est on a une
grosse tradition de rock au Québec ce
qui est vraiment cool
mais beaucoup beaucoup de fautes c'est
c'est ça qui marche bien puis il y a
tradition de chansons je trouve ça
incroyable mais je pense qu'on peut
aller dans quelque chose d'autre parce
que ça représente notre culture aussi
puis excuse-moi je t'ai coupé parce que
tu as des contenus quelqu'un d'autre moi
aussi c'est comme nouvelle signature qui
est
comme il y a un peu de gens le loup mais
ça reste du Mac Miller mélangé comme un
peu
ça parle à une génération qui est
peut-être pas la mienne mais moi j'aime
ça aussi le titre c'est super influencé
par la culture du skate puis tu sais les
clés c'est vraiment moi je trouve ça je
trouve ça incroyable
écoute ça c'est dans nos nouveaux là
était il y en a plein d'autres est-ce
que tu vas les voir où vous êtes
plusieurs j'imagine à faire ça allez
voir les choses mettons avant de un
artiste qui est indépendant
avec des gens qui piquent leurs idées
sinon souvent c'est des il y a une boîte
démo les gens s'ils veulent envoyer leur
démo
recevez beaucoup
ta voix
excellente question parce que moi j'ai
déjà envoyé un démo avec la ville manger
de la musique qu'on a fait tomber dans
le sol et on a envoyé des métiers genre
en y repensant même ils doivent pas être
écoutés on les écoute
déjà fait puis on l'a vu puis on était
quand même vraiment bon là je veux dire
c'est rare qu'on sait souvent c'est des
choses que des gens ils envoient plein
plein de monde c'est pas super
personnalisé mais lui tu sais quand il
envoyait c'était vraiment pour nous puis
on a une lettre de motivation 100% puis
on voudrait références que j'étais super
impressionné puis c'est pour ça qu'on
l'a rencontré
beaucoup de démos quand même
est-ce que des fois c'est comme dans la
littérature quand j'étais au à
l'université il me disait si tu envoies
ton ton manuscrit là faut que la
première page ce soit genre un
masterpace le faut que tu mettes tout
ton temps dans la première page pour que
le monde puisse lire la deuxième tu sais
je sais pas si c'est exactement ça je
pense que c'est comme un feeling général
tu sais il y a déjà à faire qu'on reçoit
que pour vrai ça fait aucun
connaissances avec ce qu'on propose déjà
effectuer le sexe c'est des choses qui
envoient à tout le monde
souvent est-ce que parce que est-ce que
parce que il envoie ça à tout le monde
ça part avec une prise de gens
mettons que c'est vraiment bon pourquoi
il y a pas ça c'est comme s'il y avait
un démo c'est comme parce que c'est une
boîte de mots atteint quelque chose
comme si l'envoyer à toutes les démos du
monde entier genre les affaires qui
arrivent comme de l'Afrique comme je
comprends on peut pas travailler seul
152 adresse en CC
bon alors j'avoue que ce soit des trucs
comme clairement on va pas signer ça
parce que justement
mais genre pourquoi on est là
sinon on a c'est souvent un feeling
général effectivement la personne c'est
le son look comment aller c'est
percutant ou ça nous rejoindre ok cool
la musique est-ce que c'est des fois on
a signé des gens moi si j'entaïs je l'ai
signé juste en regardant son sa
perfolaire des Francs couvertes puis
pour rester c'était vraiment comme le je
vais pas rien dire de chacun mais c'est
un peu tout proche je sais mais moi
quand je l'ai vu j'ai fait ok oui c'est
comme tout est partout mais l'essence
toi ce que tu es c'est là c'est vraiment
bon puis il faut juste que ça ça se
travaille un petit peu puis on va
t'amener à l'étape suivante aujourd'hui
est rendu elle tape suivante elle
s'améliore de jour en jour
c'est toi qui a vu ça il y a quelque
chose là c'est pas c'est pas abouti mais
c'était c'était comme il y avait quelque
chose de super bon dans mais comme
c'était tout tout décousu il fallait
vraiment qu'ils soient travailler puis
honnêtement j'avais ça comme la théorie
du diamant brut là pour les gens qui
regardent your mother il y a beaucoup de
théorie dans cette émission là et du
diamant brut c'est que c'est comme tu
trouves de quoi qui est comme toute sale
toute comme c'est pas c'est pas bien
poli rien puis ensuite tu donnes juste
un petit coup de travail puis de de
chaîne puis la personne devient
théorie de dormir absolument j'essaie
n'importe quoi prenez pas est-ce que
c'est une super image mais mais je
réfléchis je fais comme ça que c'est pas
dans Matthieu Madeleine que ça c'est
comme étant une personne aime les olives
l'autre n'aime pas les olives vous êtes
fait pour être bon c'est un bon match
mais finalement ce qu'on apprend c'est
que c'est un mensonge parce que les deux
aiment les olives puis en plus genre
toutes les théories de Burny ne font
aucun sens parce que c'est la personne
la plus misogyne
qui vieillit quand même mal alors
Mathieu Madère honnêtement fils on peut
leur écouter ça reste bon parce que
quand même la voix de la raison de Jim
PAM qui sont tout le temps là qui sont
je pense que
faire c'est que ça se verrait un
commentaire sur tout ce genre de type de
personne là fait que c'est exagéré mais
bon c'est le problème c'est que le
problème c'est que t'aide qui se posait
avec la voix de la raison des fois
c'est le pire
que tu es moche quand il repense là
je l'ai écouté souvent mais c'est sûr
après ça de la réécouter quand j'ai fini
d'office pour m'endormir j'essaie de
réécouter à mettre une moto puis j'ai
pas été capable j'ai fait dans c'est
tout match un peu
bref théorie de la du diamant brut ça
fait du sens pour moi
pour voir ça
mais ça demande un peu d'expérience
j'imagine après est-ce que moi j'ai de
l'expérience je sais pas mais si je
pense que c'est le fun maintenant j'ai
une maison disque je peux je peux le
faire
dans ce désir là
il y a des gens qui vont avoir des
spectacles et puis qui est 10h tu
aimerais-tu ça oui
tu me disais que tu voulais faire un
genre de
tinideskébécois avec bravo puis avec les
studios c'est quelque chose qui est
encore sur le projet ouais on attend que
ça soit comme vraiment super bien décoré
puis toute mon préféré des gens de
sessions après est-ce que ça marcherait
mais je pense que si on a plus de en
fait je pense ça marcherait sur
justement Tik Tok ou quelque chose comme
ça puisque YouTube maintenant
[Musique]
j'y aille aussi pour apprendre comment
faire des rénovations oui oui il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de tutoriels de
rénovation sur Youtube
pour savoir quoi
[Musique]
c'est ça que j'ai catché de toutes ces
années au Québec c'est que si tu es
proche d'un cours d'eau puis que tu fais
un spectacle les mannes tu vas manger
puis moi c'est quasiment dans mon
maintenant là je refuse des
[Musique]
concertski l'autre bord de l'eau puis
genre les mêmes
c'est le pire moment de l'année en plus
dans la momie
ils s'en vont pas c'est ça la fatigue au
moins aussi que tu peux comme le chasser
mais les manne colle c'est dégueulasse
c'est mon mon pire que tu sais
aller à la parce que les mêmes c'est des
effets morts j'étais allé à l'émission
de radio de boucardio je pense avec
le buste de traiter d'un d'un phénomène
de science nature en première partie
d'émission on va peut-être traiter d'un
phénomène de sciences humaines en
deuxième partie d'émission tout le temps
sur la même thématique plus la
thématique c'était pire tout le temps
invité musicale qui fait avec la
thématique la thématique c'était les
éphémères fait qu'au début
sur la dessus
en première partie il y a un biologiste
qui vient parler des affaires de comment
ça fonctionne en deuxième partie c'est
moi qui viens parler de la popularité
éphémère des gens qui font des
télé-réalités l'invité musicale c'était
Wilfried
mais après ça on faisait un peu le pari
est venu Jason un peu aussi de
téléréalité puis ces choses-là mais mais
ouais puis lui racontait justement où le
Fred qu'il y avait il y avait fait des
choses est-ce qu'il y en a mais ici
juste déjà
le j'accepte de manger des éphémères ah
non mais moi je peux je peux pas je peux
pas c'est c'est contre une intuitif là
tu peux pas chanter puis tu peux pas
[Rires]
sinon j'ai pas mal tout j'ai quelques
mariages cet été je sais pas pour vous
c'est la saison des mariages fait que je
j'en ai pas c'est fait qu'il faut être
là faut être puis tu célèbre
tout le monde est là pour avoir du fun
divorce
non
Québec
le Chalet des reins
mais
la France
tu vas souvent
à court moyen et long terme puis là
bah écoute que je garde de ma voix cet
été que ça se passe bien ma voix dans
tous les sens du terme
et puis
que je sais pas j'ai moyen terme je sais
pas que j'ai mon fils commence à parler
ça serait le fun ça c'est comme un autre
bulle pour bientôt
la santé la santé les belles aventures
[Musique]
merci beaucoup